Speaker 1: Let's now go to the lack of charisma
of Ron DeSantis, and we're not going to spend
a ton of time on this.
Ron DeSantis was interviewed a couple of nights
ago by Jesse Waters.
Jesse Waters is a fox.
News host who I'm aware that he now is going
to be in primetime on Fox News, thanks to
the firing of Tucker Carlson and a sort of
reorganization that went on.
And Jesse WATTERS is horrible, but Ron DeSantis
is so painfully awkward and cringe.
Here is the Santos claiming the left doesn't
want people to be happy.
And he's not really making a very good case
that that's the truth.
Speaker 3: After all this.
Why does the government do that.
Speaker 2: If they just want to control you
have an H on the left.
They want to control behavior a lot.
And we saw the same thing with COVID.
A lot of that wasn't about your health.
It was about they wanted to control your behavior.
So they just don't want people to be happy
and be able to make their own decisions.
They were going after gas stoves in Florida.
We made them tax free.
We may have to do some incentives for coal
fired pizza because you know what?
We'll take it.
Speaker 3: They're going to want us to microwave
this pizza so you're okay.
Speaker 1: And there's Ron DeSantis eating
pizza.
Eating pizza.
You know, you're really angering liberals
when you eat pizza on Fox News from a studio
in New York City.
This is supposed to make the guy likable in
some way.
This is supposed to show us that he's right
on some policy issue.
It is just pathetic.
Then the topic, by the way, of Gavin Newsom
came up, came out, came up, and Gavin Newsom
is the Democratic governor of California who
has been trolling DeSantis very hard, very
hard.
And DeSantis actually has to lie to criticize
California, which they love to do.
Speaker 3: What's with Gavin Newsom?
Speaker 2: Well, you know, I was born and
raised in Florida.
I never saw a California license plate in
my whole life in Florida.
And why would you why would.
Speaker 1: Now, I know people are going to
write to me and say, David, what is wrong
with Ron DeSantis?
Why?
Why does his head shake like that?
I am going to remind everybody, to our knowledge,
Ron DeSantis does not have a condition that
would cause any kind of shaking or tremors.
Nothing Parkinsonian.
He doesn't have tardive dyskinesia or any
of that.
If he did, we would not be pointing this out.
This is a move that Ron DeSantis does to seem
engaging and laid back.
He just has had moves like a bobblehead and
he could float on out of the screen if you're
not careful.
It's a very weird trait.
And he needs he needs some kind of a personality
transplant.
Trump was right.
Speaker 2: Leave a San Diego or Los Angeles.
And yet, since I've been governor, we've seen
a huge rush of people moving clear across
the country to leave California, leave San
Francisco, leave L.A. to come to Florida.
Nobody knows.
California had never lost population for its
entire history lie.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So that's not true.
And again, it's like states sometimes gain
population, sometimes they lose.
It can happen for a number of different reasons.
It doesn't have to be because of a woke dystopia
or whatever the case may be.
But there were multiple years in the nineties
when California lost population.
He's hanging his hat on.
This is a new thing.
It's not true.
Speaker 2: Until he became governor.
And so I think he sees people leaving.
I think he sees that there's deterioration
and I think he's lashing out.
Speaker 3: Do you think Newsom is trying to
be next in line and Kamala Harris?
Well, you.
Speaker 2: Know, what I told him is stop messing
around on the sidelines like either do it
or not.
Like, are you going to take on Joe?
If so, step into the ring and do it.
And so I think he's kind of maneuvering in
the in the background.
But, you know, that would be interesting to
see if Biden doesn't ultimately make it how
that resolves it.
Speaker 3: Do you think Biden is going to
make it?
Speaker 2: Look, I think that people want
to move on from Biden.
I think that's very, very clear.
I don't know if he's going to get that message.
And so he may very well try to stick it out.
We'll be ready for for whoever, because I
think the thing about the Democrat Party is,
yeah, Biden has got huge problems.
We all know that.
But we talk about this corruption.
What does he have going for him?
Harris Is his impeachment insurance.
Speaker 3: No matter what Biden does.
Speaker 2: Nobody wants Harris.
And so it's almost like just let him finish
out.
Speaker 1: And by the way, let him finish
rather than impeaching.
Wouldn't it be good for there to be something
to impeach Joe Biden over?
SANDERS Like, as a matter of political strategy,
I don't know that impeaching him makes sense.
How about is there any reason to impeach him?
It's sort of like the stuff with the crimes.
Does it matter that there's no evidence of
criminality nor charges, nor an indictment?
No.
It's just like, do we want to charge him or
not?
Is really all that matters at this point with
these people.
So DeSantis just making very little sense.
And I'll be honest, I don't know who DeSantis
actually is getting any traction with.
It's certainly not the broader Republican
electorate.
And when he goes to a dinner, it's extremely
awkward.
I don't know who likes the Santos here.
Actually, there's a woman that goes to my
gym who's been wearing a DeSantis tank top
for a while, so I guess I could ask her.
Here is DeSantis weighing in on the loyalty
question that Donald Trump has brought up
so many times.
Speaker 3: Trump says you're disloyal.
Do you feel that way?
Speaker 2: Disloyal to who?
I mean, you know, politicians have to earn
support.
They're not entitled to support.
I did a lot for him in 2016 and 2020, by the
way, was happy to do it.
Oh, yeah.
But at the end of the day, you know, I'm loyal
to my family, to our Constitution and to the
good Lord.
And I have a vision.
I think I'm the guy that can beat Biden.
But even more importantly, no more excuses
on these issues.
I'm going to get all of this stuff done.
We'll have a plan on day one to get going
and get cracking.
Give you two great terms for eight years and
really get the country on a fundamentally
different path.
I think I'm the guy to do it.
And so I have the responsibility to step up
and serve.
Speaker 1: There you go.
And you can really feel the energy and the
enthusiasm and the fact that DeSantis really
is going to get all of these things done,
isn't he?
You can really just tell.
So, listen, it's the entire loyalty thing
there.
These are both clowns when it comes to loyalty.
I'm talking about Trump and DeSantis.
Trump's view is DeSantis isn't loyal because
he decided to run against Trump after Trump
supported him.
This is politics.
Okay.
Let's pull up our big boy pants and let's
realize that this is politics.
This isn't you know, it's not gin rummy or
whatever this is.
This is just kind of the way it is.
And if you're going to be this much of a snowflake
TRUMP I'm talking about, it's going to be
tough to have success in other areas.
And Trump is, of course, struggling for success
from the point of view of DeSantis.
The idea of invoking God and saying, my loyalty
is to God rather than to Trump, again, it's
I know it's a small thing, but it's another
one of these examples of how they constantly
have to drag in religion to civil government
positions.
He's running for a position in civil government,
should have nothing to do whatsoever with
God, but he just can't resist